any advice you'd give to aspiring
creators get good at making videos which
is that you think is like be good at it
because I think often people are so
determined to find hacks and cheats
can you provide value through a video to
somebody are you making them laugh are
you educating them are you entertaining
them if you're answering to that
question yes then great and the best way
to do that is by making videos I don't
agree that YouTube is too saturated and
that you can't start a YouTube career
now that's absolutely rubbish there are
people now with 10 subscribers who will
have 10 million subscribers in three
years time we've got a framework that we
have for our YouTube course stuff which
is level one is get going level two is
get good level threes get smart yeah and
get smart is where you worry about your
Niche and stuff yeah and get good at
making a video Once you once you can do
that once a week then or whatever
consistency you want at that point let's
talk about your nation and retention
tactics and all of that crap that what
thumbnail you're gonna use
foreign